good morning everyone thank you for
coming to my talk I welcome you at NDC
Oslo hope you're enjoying the conference
now we're going to talk about f-sharp
language and why it's so suitable for
modeling the business domain so let's
get acquainted something's not working
sorry
stop apologizing
so my name is Mihaly and I love have
sharp basically that's everything you
need to know about me maybe also the
time a.net developer for more than 10
years I don't know something like that
but let's better talk about you who is
familiar with f-sharp here ok quite a
lot of people maybe this talk won't be
that interesting for you since I'm here
I'm trying to show the beauty of f-sharp
but for others might be interesting and
by the way what about dotnet developers
here ok so many things will be familiar
for you so just briefly about F sharp F
sharp is a multi paradigm language but
with the focus on functional functional
programming so it's functional first
language more to that it has an awesome
algebraic data type system with pattern
matching I will show what that means a
bit later also F sharp is a
cross-platform thanks to dotnet core or
you can use mono it's pretty stable but
nowadays dotnet core is the future
later on it won't be even named net core
we just don't need and it works on all
platforms like Windows Linux Mac OS even
I don't know Androids that's great one
more benefit of F sharp is that it can
be transpired to JavaScript thanks to a
project called fable so basically you
can use f sharp everywhere like on
back-end on front-end wherever you want
also it's a scripting language so really
everywhere like f-sharp could be on the
server on the browser even in your
scripts deploying the build and deploy
scripts and it has an awesome community
really supportive and helpful everywhere
and yeah so why would I even bother
about f-sharp or any other language
because I'm a.net developer and many
people connect dotnet and c-sharp like
putting equal sign in between them and
c-sharp is good enough for most of us
maybe but there are some things which
which are kind of weird for me first of
all one while reading like the code and
supporting it I would like to know what
what the programmer meant trying to
write this code to design some logic and
a nose model some business domain I
would like to see the intention but what
I usually get some uncertainty simple
example there is another service which
gives you it gives you a list of orders
maybe not all orders there are some
filtering but doesn't matter it should
return a list of order but what can
possibly go wrong
it could be a now there could be an
exception and you never know but from
the signature of that method I expect a
list a list of orders nothing else it
could be empty right but it must be
there
sometimes it's not they're also nulls
right so we always need to check for now
going back to that example there there
are you know there could be an awl or
exception here we always need to check
for now there are a lot of guards which
takes a lot of lines of code well it
could be a bit simpler big shorter but
still only look the business logic
finally goes somewhere lower somewhere
below and you need to read through a lot
of things also there is a huge keyword
noise like all those public static breed
only void even close instruct we all
know what that means of course reference
types value types where they are stored
in the memory and where what is what and
when you use the way you need to use
that but quite often we use just Clause
even for data types like showing some
some some object a business object just
the class very often with getting set of
the properties which makes it mutable
and also not good that's another thing
which bothers me while reading the code
I see a lot of those keywords and that
hides the real value that the logic
behind all that noise type definitions I
know that's not the best syntax
highlighting but what is that I mean
what's the name of it
oh yeah grew by right but behind all
this what how do I find it yeah okay
syntax highlighting helps okay but still
a lot of a lot of noise
since like.net and c-sharp is also not
only verbal language it's also an
object-oriented language mainly like
imperative and object-oriented language
we could find some weird naming
like I didn't know that this image could
be familiar for you imagine indoor
session initializer just a door right
like why would we name it that we're Lee
actually that goes too far sometimes and
we can see something like that I hope
you won't ever see that in real life
code but you know sometimes we find
really really strange and weird name in
quite long some of you might say and
what we are programmers like we you need
to know this is our job we need to know
what that means
we that's our book that's how we make
money we that what differs us from other
people and that's fine that's fine I
don't think so actually I'm I would say
there's something wrong so well really a
while writing the code and they're
reading it what B grades to write just
plain English right and just just plain
English describe what you want what do
you mean what are the real-life objects
you describe and then just give it to
the compiler and the compiler produces
an application do awesome want it
I have an example while working with
business analysts non-technical people
let's say not really technical people
and I had a task like a project a small
project we had to implement just a
simple feedback form on the support
tickets how well the support team worked
on that so there were a couple of
Smiley's you choose if it's sad or happy
and maybe some comment so a simple
really simple form but it had to be done
in different languages like I don't know
ten languages whatever so we ended up
with just a simple JSON file with a key
and value for each label for each string
and I send it over to the business
analyst asking please feeling filling
this JSON file with just the values for
different languages sounds simple right
sounds like why what could be easier if
there is Thank You then it should be
thank you and I don't know in the region
tuck something like that right so it's
simple but my request was rejected I was
told that this is code guys this is code
and we won't do that that's your job to
write code and we can provide you
translations what how like okay in excel
file but again that would be a table
with keys and various what's the
difference right but even there is
simple format of JSON format was carry
for them like that scared people with
all those curly braces I don't know
double quotes Collins
I don't know they for them it was scary
and everything is different for those
non-technical for business people
it's absolutely different thing the
naming is like really differs
we are used to such names as float it's
nothing new for us or integer right but
for them it's just a number they don't
think and they those categories like
float integer no it's just it's just
number yeah that could be there could be
a point floating point they would rather
call it decimal if even call it
differently than number then there is a
guide guiit right that's something
really strange for them and even string
for them it's just a text if it's a one
line of text then maybe it's fine just
line but not string you so the
conclusion here is that we just speak
different languages just different
languages they don't use our categories
we could use theirs because we know our
domain and we can know their domain but
kinda programmers would say that's fine
again that's fine we do our job they do
other job but then we end up with
different naming different different
naming of the same object and and we
sometimes trying to find the the piece
of the part of the code where we need to
maintain and make a change it's hard
because the naming coming from business
people is different so do we have to
speak different languages with them I
think no but then we need another
probably another programming language
some so expressive language that you
could write basically through the code
in comments uncomment tweak a bit make
it compile and then should it should
work so that's how f sharp from my phone
to you works let's see how if sharp in
real life helps us with to do that we
can model the domain with just types
there are a lot of different ways to do
that in F sharp but let's start with
something simple which is a
discriminated union also known as a some
type for C sharp developers that could
look like like an enum and here probably
it is like looks like an enum but it's
not into it snot a number it's not an
integer right so it's just the type with
the value of some name with some label
very simple thing it's a currency could
be either dollar euro or Norwegian krone
but discriminated unions can have some
extra data that extra data comes again
statically typed so here we can we have
a type weather and it's it could be
either sunny sunny or procedure it has
some precipitation or windy pay
attention to to to the float with m/s
this is not a regular float this is a
statically typed m/s the speed of the
wind and thanks to see unit symbols you
can use all those from all the
fellas from from see all those units
from see table on the bottom you can see
how how we initialized values with with
the type weather all of them all these
three values are of type whether either
sunny or some precipitation the very
important word here is or it can be
either one thing or another
so also sometimes it's called choice
type a very simple thing for modeling
something or how would you do that in
c-sharp I don't even know we can have I
don't know some interface and
implementations of that interface
different but it's not exhaustively
right so we we would be able to
introduce another implementation and how
it goes no one knows but those
discriminated unions we can have pattern
matching so it's a simple function
that's how we define a function in in F
sharp pretty simple thing look there are
no keywords almost there are no I don't
know curly braces no semicolons nothing
really scary so what you can see is that
a function called print weather expects
an argument of type weather look a type
weather I haven't defined it but it's
there it's statically tied because
thanks to type inference and then there
is a pattern matching which is almost
plain English right match weather with
with something with sunny then printed
sunny weather and then if we match it
with some precipitation which we named P
here for polite just for brevity we will
print that weather with some
precipitation so you can see that it's
almost plain English even here what
could be seen
I really love that one more great thing
about discriminated union is that it has
a way to use just a single case so here
card number is a tie but it also has
just one case with a label card number
which is which has the extra extra data
of type string and the card number can
be initialized with just card number in
the card number goes further like while
operating with these types you don't
even need strings integers floats
nothing like that you just use card
number which is exactly the same thing
which a business person would call it
it's a card number no one cares that
it's a string or it's a sequence of some
symbols its accessory it's just a card
number and we all know the formatter one
more type type of types in F sharp is
record records is a product type it's a
reference type by default but it's
compared by values so all those quality
members are overridden you don't need
them to do that it's not malleable by
default and it must be initialized
obviously and it's immutable and unless
you just mark it explicitly that it's
mutable basically in functional
programming or maybe in F sharp
programming we are we tend to make
everything explicit everything should be
visible right when you read the code you
don't need to think of Oh
there could be possible now or something
else or exception everything should be
visible explicit a record simple example
this is a definition of a person and
this is the initialization of a person
we initialize a value
person with these properties you cannot
you cannot define just some of them it's
they're all mandatory so basically there
is and let's say one constructor with
all arguments assigned at the moment of
initialization really simple thing again
look there is type there is no
mentioning of a class or a struct we
don't bother we just say it's a type and
we know that it's a type and that's a
business object yeah we can make it
destruct if we need that that's possible
but by default it will be a reference
type this is a combination now for the
discriminated union and records I
believe this can be that's readable for
non-technical people so the mayor the
main type which were interested in is on
the bottom its payment basically the
payment object and it can have some
amount some currency and method and you
see there are no keywords here no
programming keywords because for
business person again the currency is a
currency our amount is a payment amount
yes a bit above we define that a payment
amount is actually a type of decimal but
then in your business logic you operate
with payment amount not with a decimal
and the check number is an integer and
the card number is a string but again
you have parade with them just as it is
a card number and the card and the check
number as business people would do for
them it's not a string for them it's not
an integer again
this is another example let's imagine
yeah let's imagine a med store which
sells some gadgets and the gadget can
have some code and for for example for
phones it's a string and for a tablet
it's an integer but for a business
person again it's a phone cord and a
tablet code and at the end it's a gadget
code so we end up with the type gadget
with a code of type gadget code very
simple and we operate these names and
categories later on in your business
logic and by the way you can define your
units of measure just with a simple
attribute measure and then you get other
grams or inches which we used for the
weight and screen size
you probably know the name not the name
the saying like make your invalid state
on representable so this is how we also
do in F sharp and that's great way to
approach it so for different states
maybe even over the same entity of the
same object we use different state
different types let's say we have an
order and it has some shipping address
but we don't know if it's real it's if
it's valid or if it's just some random
address so before that before we process
the order when it comes from the user
we just we know that the address is not
validated yet so for us it's one state
of basically it's a different thing it's
just Nora it's not even a state it's
just a different different thing it's
just some input I wouldn't call it even
an order it doesn't have an even order
ID or something like that it's just an
input often of a user so it has an
unvalidated address and there isn't
order when we already processed the
validated it and we now have a validated
order it's a different type and we can
have also a type which is basically kind
of a verb so it's the definition of a
father it's a signature of a function
unvalidated address is somehow validated
and can output either a validated
address or not so if you remember nulls
here we don't have no civil a dated
address cannot be cannot be now but we
need to explicitly say that the value
can be missing there could be not a
validated address because the input was
incorrect
that's that's way here an option type
helps this is a simple definition of an
option type of a bit and actually it's a
bit more complicated in the F sharp
libraries but this is the simplest
definition it's either some of some type
some real validated address in this case
or none and we see it immediately when
we look at this signature of a method or
function we see that the address can be
missing the validated address is
optional no now's no we don't need to
think about it and that's also great
more to that there is a specific special
result type imagine something goes wrong
like I don't know an API is not
available not accessible databases down
something goes wrong in your in the
workflow what would you do throw an
exception that's usual but then you need
to catch all of them what if some
validation fails you need to what would
you return an owl or something result
type will help you a lot so it's either
some success or failure it statically
typed its generic here and if we have a
function which takes an unpaid invoice
and the payment it can result either
with a paid invoice if everything goes
well if the pain I'm in gateways ready
to answer like everything really okay or
it's a payment error and that's visible
from the first glance you see like
immediately that the result can be
either paid invoice or payment error
this actually works with lists of
validation errors in this case the list
by the way look it's very simple again
it's just
datian error list what could be simpler
how how simpler would you write that I
believe for non-technical people even
that will be clear so there are pretty
simple ways to combine the validation
errors from from separate values into a
list and wrap them into result we won't
cover it here so result with specific
success and failure types really helps
to understand the intention of the of
the function by the way discriminated
unions can also be used for different
states of the same object here we have a
shopping cart which can be either empty
or active or Beit card and the basically
the the the fields the values of the
fields could be different so for an
empty card there are no items right and
for active car they could be items but
they are not paid and there is no
payment obviously and then again we can
match it pattern match it very simply
match card with empty card and that's it
we just plain English right so if we
want to add an item to the card this
particular item we match the card with
empty card then we return an active card
with just an item in unpaid items I
don't know for me that's the simplest
way to describe the real business logic
the plain English almost plain English
since we are talking about functional
programming we of course use functions
and not classes there are no abstract
factories I don't know there are no
builders whatever like those all those
objective oriented patterns well of
course you can apply some of them but
that's not needed you can compose all
your logic from functions and functions
are really powerful in F sharp since
yeah of course it's functional first
language so let's see starting from the
type inference this is the way I also
already showed you the way we define the
function so we don't write function we
don't write no we don't necessarily
write the types for arguments or for
return values it can be inferred from
the context but if you want to you can
do that the line six shows you how to
define arguments with specific types
there is no return keyword as you can
see also one benefit so everything is
clear the last expression in the
function will be the return value of the
function on the line nine week you can
see that we firstly we define the type
of the function and then on the line 11
we just say that II D float function is
of type and float so it returns a
function with two arguments and which
returns a float for us and then we just
use the function with just again no
parenthesis no curly braces no no is
just the real real value the real logic
the real name of of the of the thing
yeah as in previous example we can just
define the types of our functions
firstly and then just have them
implemented very simple thing I don't
know they I don't see any noise here
from my live interview there is just
very neat definition of of the parts of
the code of the of the workflow one more
great thing is BiPAP rater which can
help you to reverse the the the calling
like if you have a function is some in
option type you can pass an optional
address there but with the pipe operator
you can reverse these things and it will
be optional address is some like I can
plain English if optional address is
some then do something let's say like
like it's a simple example so with pipe
operator we really use plain English
instead of all those parenthesis and a
lot of parenthesis this is how it helps
to compose the workflow actually so you
can see we have several functions and
then instead of assigning each result of
each function to some variable and then
pass it further we don't do that we
just right in the order of execution so
an validated order goes to firstly
validate order and price worth and
acknowledged orders and create events
otherwise we would need to either put a
lot of parentheses around that or assign
each very each result variable which is
not a variable in F sharp its value
everything is immutable by default oh
yeah actually here I'm a bit lying to
you that won't work because as you can
see the return values a result and the
arguments expected are not results so we
need a bit of binding and mapping but
still if we just look at this it's not
that noisy and actually you can define
your own operators and avoid this result
bind that just replace it with this
simple operator someone would say it's
even more complicated like you need to
remember a lot of operators you don't
have to you can use this approach that's
all suppose I didn't show you a partial
application what that means
so all functions in F sharp are carried
so you can pass just not each of each
argument at the same time you can pass
just one or some just part of the
required arguments and you will get a
function back so for example if you have
a function add with two arguments if you
pass just one where we get a function
which expects the last argument and then
we can pass that one and receive the
real value that
can be helpful the partial application
is the equivalent of dependency
injection in object-oriented programming
so this example is a bit more
complicated but it shows us that we have
a function validate order and it expects
three dependencies check product code
exists check address exists two
dependencies right and one unvalidated
order what we can do we can pass to
those dependencies firstly and get
another function back we can even call
it the same way which is called
shadowing and at the end our validate
order found now here it's sorry it's a
typo so validate order function is just
a function of one argument you need to
pass only unvalidated order to it and
that's it so that's how you in one place
of your application may be on there
somewhere on startup you create those
functions passing only dependencies to
them and then you get back the functions
with just the final argument in this
case unvalidated order so partial
application is maybe the one of the most
powerful and important parts in
functional programming without that I
don't think we would be able to do
anything there is no such thing in
c-sharp and I don't think it will ever
happen there yeah so just use F sharp
you can actually have imperative style
in your code you don't have to use all
those pipes not necessarily even here I
use pipes just to change the order but
you yeah you can see that I just assign
values to some not variables to values
and then pass them to create events
function that's also possible and could
be maybe readable a bit more readable
for people unfamiliar with F sharp so if
you are starting with F sharp probably
that's the way to go
and then step by step you apply all
those functional techniques but yeah you
can start with this
actually I'm I'm a bit too fast here but
yeah just to give credit to Scott
flushing all this talk is inspired by
this book if you read the one from Eric
Evans well if you haven't read the one
that just domain-driven design by Eric
Evans you don't need that here you can
read this book with examples in F sharp
and that would be more than enough to
understand how to model the the domain
how to write the domain driven
domain-specific language in F sharp
which is probably the most suitable
language for that Scott lotion also has
an article about F sharp why it's the
best enterprise language he is the owner
of F sharp for fun and profit com
website where you can find a lot of
examples and a lot of articles how to
use F sharp and in enterprise and not
only there is also an article F sharp
for see sharp developers so feel free to
to read it and also I would encourage
you to look at the safe stack which is
really great set of technologies for
functional programming for a full stack
functional programming development web
development with F sharp as I told you
you can write back-end and front-end
code so save stack is really helpful
here
and that's basically it from my side
today I'm a bit really too too fast but
yeah that that's it thank you all for
coming and if you have any questions I
will be happy to answer them yes please
yep
yes
well you're not that limited actually I
mean that all those discriminated unions
all those labels are also transported on
job into JavaScript and with some
encoders and decoders like simple Jason
or thought you can use they are
serialized into Jason and beg this
realize to the same to the same types
and models which you have in F sharp so
it's one to one and back so I don't see
a limitation here actually yes under the
hood there's it's JSON is JavaScript so
there is no I don't know if there is
even no double or float whatever well
you can work around them again with
again strings and then in in in F sharp
you would be able to parse them because
feeble allows you to transpile even the
framework in the BCL types directly into
javascript and back so I don't think
it's it's a huge problem actually so you
can do a lot anyway there are
limitations right but not that much like
not that many you can yeah yeah with the
pattern of Fable remoting for example
you can even not write you can avoid
even calling the API manually this is
just RPC style so there's shared model
in a separate project probably and then
you call a function and get that object
in Java T in Fable in JavaScript or on
the server side it's pretty simple so I
don't see that much probably many
problems here
so if that's it then thank you